el affitti ragazzi e prevenuto questo
momento sono farisei che da oggi siamo
su chi è a 6
siamo su van der burgh la debacle
e cazzo si dice che il club belga de bei
ragazzi veramente sarebbero sarebbe tipo
vacchino atf quello doveva ammazzare il
labbro solo che è diverso questi
sarebbero i lati e che belle c'è un
perfetti che c'è la delicatezza di un
ninja quello sono io non ti ho scoperto
in un nanosecondo per carità di dio
istruzioni trova tutti i modi per
uccidere decisiva ma è normale come
wired
mi piace il cane whisky tappeto a darci
tutto posso usare qualsiasi cosa come
prima cosa usiamo il cane voglio vedere
cosa fa
l'oggetto serve serve qualcos'altro per
farlo funzionare che il cane più che
cazzo ne sono lo specchio cane si porta
è e cosa fa il cane più la porta
[Musica]
cosa è uscita la nonna dalla porta
spiega vincent vero e come mia nonna
quando mi dice di mangiare la stessa
cosa
porca eva eccolo qua qua a mio nonno non
ci arriva si fermava prima hai una voce
sensuale è che è pronta la sera ci
mancava quello non avevo dubbi
il problema non era là del problema e se
mangiamo è morto ma è morto quindi wilde
e barberi che figo sembra molto più
violento degli altri enti la questone
botti blocchetti tenda con le tende
tenda più quindi devo dire qualsiasi
cosa voluta sia andato in massa tenda
più mazza per quale motivo guarda che
non scialando a posto e morto a devo
strangolarlo
cinque minuti dopo a madonna ragazzi
pronto per andare in macelleria proprio
bellissimo e non si è fatto neanche
troppo male per carità è viva viva
ancora vivo da città vocal step bello e
ora puoi goderti il pomeriggio saranno
conto nonna che cucina comunque ragazzi
ce ne sono 17 di cose allo specchio a sé
addio guarda come sei bella nello
specchio bello eh ti piace questo
bello
questa voce entità è che giornata di
merda
il tappeto con l'orso si può usare a più
più qualcos'altro più cammino più lo
speck più le candele lampadario fra
oggetti nicchia camino tutti insieme
ragazzo serio perche non ho ucciso io
della [ __ ] e quindi devo usare dal
progetto giusto se non muoio sono molto
pochi che sarà impossibile giusto è
giusto che ho lanciato dei soldi sul
tappeto giu senso faccio cadere il
lampadario
ovviamente io ho un libro che fa cadere
il lampadario perché giustamente 6
meglio così comunque se stai bene pelato
e adesso mi spiegate l'utilità di un
libro che fa cadere in un lampadario che
non la capisco che cazzo di casa poi uno
lo tocca per sbaglio crolla al soffitto
vabbè telecomando telecomando
telecomando più videogiochi raccomando
più mia nonna quando mazza da baseball
che devo tirare una x6
thomas g il famosissimo thomas g network
channel
ma cos'è ma no ma no tagli stame
vorresti entrarci dentro che dentro le
reti eccolo che centrato come esaudire i
sogni delle persone ragazzi su tuerk
channel adesso i culi sono anche in 3d
fantastico facciamo il camino solo il
camino a qualcosa centrale comando certo
ovvio no no no no no sto giocando a call
of duty
ora tranquilla donna cio l'audio alto ma
eccolo qui team che sta sparando un
ladro per carità di dio come è morto
un'ora fa al pizzi ha però dato perché
si sente ancora lo sparo che è finito da
un'ora e mezza in realtà è e l'eco della
stanza che dura un bel pò carino al
fuoco e candela ficazione candela più
candela candela più candela candelari
carriera ricca di merano è sbagliato
kimono c'era un kimono candela più
candela più kimono map che ci fa un
kimono sul pavè cinque minuti dopo
perché lei ovviamente ragazzo il ladro
aspetta cinque minuti senza tirare fuori
la pistola cosa che
ma dove l'hai tirato fuori va beh no è
andato da mia nonna adesso morirà
mangiando va bene flash player flash nel
trash nerl più cigar sigaro dare
informativa a vuoi fare un tiro nella
serve l'accendino zio prendo io prendo
io e tranquillo
eccolo qua mi sono preso addio eccolo
accenni a come dimagrire in 5 milioni
anche in dieci secondi veniva dj lynch
alle tattiche complicarsi le diete
sarebbe un cazzo cavatappi cavata per
katherine cavatappi sul davanzale si si
si
ecco che posso tapparci la bambina di
televisore li mortacci tua
ganau rischi non toccare mi schiera ve
l'ho detto io non l'ho addestrato a
queste cose ma non lo vedono bene di
whisky vai da nonna bravo e vabbè
animale come ornamento in realtà
potrebbe fare riprendere una fontana
umana da qualche parte che mi sta
appoggiando sul mio cane come se niente
fosse invece il sigaro e basta posso
ucciderlo solo consiglio cosa faccio
prendersi garate in testa gli ho
soffiato in faccia ovvio
se in volta frate attento al birillo
attento al birillo che fa male questo
fronte
no non può più solo o meglio mi sembrava
sbagliato come per i piedi sul cane
mettiamoli supporto whisky a cosa
serviva a niente
faccio umbri a carpi che non crepi
poteva lancio o farcela molotov anomalo
neanche si è rotto rischi che non si
rompe giusto buon natale
lo zio però ci hanno detto che non
possiamo fare i fuochi che stanno in
qualche modo ci dobbiamo divertire non
vai a fare un po di intrattenimento
fuori bravo bravo e così che la all
complimenti che fai a sei fermato si
chiama è morto ai libri in faccia l'ho
sempre detto io che i libri fa male ma
pronto è bello ancora uno anche libro di
storia ti passava quello che cazzoni che
c'è un cubo di rubik perfetto in realtà
è così che si risolve il cubo di rubik
ragazzi la lotta all attivazione
a posso prenderla proprio a giusto mi
scusi mi dà un'occhiata alla lampada
fine si è rotta è loro taglio per
sbaglio e giovanni fi
porca eva tanta violenza muntain bleach
l'ho vista come morto ma leporino
ragazzi non credete alle lampade le
lampade sono cattive persone video games
e videogames più cosa videogames più chi
più sa è una spada quella no ma
seriamente ma finisce bene ma bello
fatality ragazzi non è ancora morto è
zio non è ancora morto attenzione a noi
morto è morto
come non detto sembrava che fossi
sembrava fosse ancora vivo ma in realtà
è morto a me usciamo col cuscino ragazzi
cuscino me lo dovete spiegare cos'è
quella roba lì ho preso il cuscino non
quello aprendo il cuscino lo metti sopra
ok
ovviamente non sono neanche pensato
ma la camera con che con che rabbia lo
sta uccidendo
annoiato quando hai la e la vita è così
zio sai mai come cazzo intrattenerti
pomeriggio i ragazzi prega tutto il
giorno che anche nell'agro in casa per
ucciderlo prega che succede fire poker
giustamente poi si può giocare a poker
col fuoco ragazzi mi ero dimenticato
questa cosa fa il poker più incerto cosa
faccio
ragazzi questo sono io uguale identico
preciso ma non è morto ma chrome è la
cosa che a noi va bene un ciclo non ho
ucciso scappate basta finché è scappato
è ancora vivo in teoria va beh ti sei
salvato zio miracolo che cosa minchia è
questo whiskers c'è un [ __ ] gatto
sulla poltrona seriamente ragazzino
l'amica visto il cane cane ovvio che
cosa c'è un gatto sulla poltrona non ho
mica visto micam in zona per ciò attira
angelis
gli schermi perché io amo il mio gatto
secolo marone è staccato un marrone
torna come se niente fosse sulla
poltrona gatto dell'anno tra povero
ragazzo finito purché 17 l'ho finito gli
iron lochhead kitsch anch'io sono le
uccisioni in cucina ma va serio ma no ci
sarà c'è anche l'altro l'altro 13
fantastico perché ora ragazzi faccio un
altro episodio poi sull'altra 13 che se
non facciamo tipo 30 in un episodio solo
fantastico comunque che bello io sono
ancora uno dopo non mi ricordo quindi
ragazzo listino che vi sia piaciuto cose
di solito milito al momento è un mi
piace anche a faccia di facebook e come
nei video tratte in description si
discute ci vediamo un po subito ai
ragazzi
[Musica]